horrible women's health news from Texas
may be sort of a preview of what's going
to happen under the Donald Trump
administration in July Texas state
health officials quietly proposed new
rules requiring what amounts to funeral
arrangements anytime a woman loses or
terminates a pregnancy outside of her
home we're basically talking about
funeral like procedures for embryos and
this will by all likelihood go into
effect in all likelihood before the end
of 2016 a quote from Alexa Ora at the
Texas Tribune despite intense outcry
from the medical community and
reproductive rights advocates the state
will prohibit hospitals abortion clinics
and other health care facilities from
disposing of fetal remains in sanitary
landfills instead allowing only
cremation or burial of all remains
regardless of the period of gestation
david brown is a staff attorney for the
center for reproductive rights who says
even when the embryo is so small as to
be invisible the doctor or health care
provider will still have to treat it
like a dead person and have some kind of
burial or cremation for it what's the
goal here the goal is to shame women who
don't bring pregnancy to term to
contribute to try to control what women
are doing with their bodies and women's
health advocates known in the rational
world as sane people are worried that
this might dissuade women who need
medical care from seeking treatment well
yes just like making abortion illegal
encourages women to seek what are
colloquially referred to as back-alley
abortions that is exactly the impact
that this is going to have and what's
going on in the background of this
insanity in Texas well an NPR
investigation says that there's already
significant evidence that a large number
of Texas women are turning to what they
call and this is just horrible DIY
abortion methods rather than going to a
doctor however and this is the most
interesting part of this the most
popular method is not the back-alley
abortion per se but a drug called
misoprostol
which can induce miscarriage and this
really reminds me of many of the issues
with these anti choice nuts pad number
one how do you ban something that we're
clearly going in the direction of women
being able to do for themselves in their
own homes more and more safely the
colloquial back-alley abortion horrible
bad for women's health really really bad
when you're talking about drugs like
misoprostol and the ability to induce
pregnancy in the safety of your own home
that is a direction that medical science
is going it's gonna make the hardline
anti-abortion stuff more and more
difficult but it's also an issue of how
these laws disproportionately impact
poor people in a way that you would
think conservatives would want to avoid
unwanted children born to poor parents
are more likely to be children in
poverty are more likely to therefore end
up with worse educational and
professional outcomes which leads to
more crime incarceration and even more
unwanted kids you would think that
Republicans wouldn't want to do
something that is going to lead to more
of the problems they claim to want to
solve but it all goes back to this
amorphous idea of idea of morality
doesn't it and think of all the things
that the Republicans have been able to
do even when Roe vs. Wade is on the
books and the in the position that it is
now yeah I mean closing down many
different abortion clinics in a state so
that you have to travel long distances
you're requiring parental consent and if
that if that law is overturned that's
just gonna open up a whole nother can of
worms it is and fortunately it's not
like how Donald Trump said it happens
which is just oh I'll appoint Supreme
Court justices who will be pro-life and
then instantly roe v wade is
automatically overturned it doesn't
happen that way but yes Supreme Court
picks could have a very very very big
impact on that and you know at the the
last thing I want to mention and I know
I've said this ad nauseam we know how to
prevent abortions from even being sought
out number one comprehensive sex
education conservatives are against that
number two free access to birth control
and information about how to use it way
way cheaper than the cost of abortions
way way cheaper than the societal cost
of unwanted children but unfortunately
conservatives are against that as well